for three years the staff at this
nursery have to nurture the seedlings
carefully until they're strong enough to
survive on their own in the hot soil of
the desert
the people who live here in the
loup-garou gene are working to stop the
relentless advance of the Sahara
Senegal's government has passed
stringent laws to help protect the newly
green Daria's population here is only
allowed to cut down trees to build
housing authorities are very strict
about ensuring that only dead wood is
cut that scream that still living can't
be harvested
but despite the ban people still
regularly help themselves to firewood
after dark the Senegalese government has
now fenced in large parts of the region
to keep out cows and goats long term it
says trees and grass are the only way to
fight climate change the country is
participating in the great green wall
project the project got its start in
Senegal back in 2008 it's an initiative
that's now supported by many of the
African nations that border on the
Sahara in Senegal we're planting almost
550 square kilometers of trees so far we
finished about a hundred and fifty of
that 11 countries are now working on the
great green wall project which stretches
over 7,000 700 kilometers and all from
Senegal in the West to Djibouti in the
East there are two really major problems
the first is the expense of the fencing
itself out here it costs around 3000
euros to set up one kilometer of fence
and the second problem is water the
seedlings and saplings need to get
enough of it but the women also need
water for their gardens in the village
of coyly eyford the number of jobs at
the nursery and in gardening has grown
the women here now plant beans squash
and potatoes in the desert the
government is helping by drilling wells
some 200 metres deep this project has
brought many benefits
like our children now spend more time
with their fathers the men used to be
out with the herds for days at a time
looking for food and water now
everything is here we have houses a
school and the produce we grow keeps us
healthy and that's good because there
are no doctors here the village is
receiving important visitors today along
with a government representative a UN
delegation is in town the UN is
supporting the project in cooperation
with the European Union and World Bank
if you want to fight climate change if
you want to fight against soul
degradation because there is soil
degradation here you need to have this
kind of conservative approaches you need
to to think in terms of agro ecology to
use less fertilizer less pesticide so
for the people of coyly alpha are just
happy that they're profiting from the
motto project and they hope that
Senegal's government will continue to
pump water and money into their village
[Music]